remember the good old days when you
could go to a concert and you could
thrive off all that energy in the crowd
well bands want it back and they're
looking for ways to perform onstage in
front of a live audience Canadian
country music star Brett Kissel seems to
have cracked it he's come up with a kind
of throwback solution drive-in concerts
kind of like drive-in theaters you pull
up stay in your vehicle and listen to
the band Brett Kissel talked to me from
the stage in Edmonton on Friday Brett so
good to talk to you I love the slogan on
your website tough times don't last
tough people do give us the basics of
how these drive-in concerts of yours are
gonna work well I really appreciate that
tough times don't last stuff people do
as a model that I live by it's one of my
songs we actually just re-released it
for the weekend and I'm really excited
that we get to play that show for our
concerts our show here that we're doing
and all eight of them are very unique
because there's no speakers hung up on
the stage as you can see what it is is
that people are gonna hear our show
through the radio dials so we perform
into our soundboard a sound board into
an FM transmitter transmitter into
everybody's car stereos we're just
asking that everybody honked their horns
when they like the song that they hear
oh nice so honking instead of clapping I
guess and I the idea is nobody gets out
of their vehicles right that's right I
mean safety is a huge concern for us we
have to make sure that everybody's going
to be safe but also have a great time so
we've got all of these rules on our
website drivin Brett Kissel calm where
we say some of these I guess scary rules
but we put a little country spin on them
so one of the big things was no
washrooms so please go before the show
and also no no tailgating we know
everybody wants to but stay in your
vehicle so we can entertain you through
the radio dial and what kind of response
have you've been getting Howard ticket
sales it's been amazing for us to have
been able to sell out eight shows in
under an hour
when we put tickets on sale a couple of
weeks ago was something that really
shattered my expectations but one of the
really cool things is that both of the
shows that we are doing to you know
obviously to start our weekend has
this it's for the frontline workers
first responders health care heroes so
those first two shows have been free but
the other ones are obviously for the
general public what's really cool is
that thanks to our partnership with
Safeway Canada 100% of our proceeds go
straight to the food banks here in
Alberta that way we can do a lot of good
and raise a lot of money for a cause and
an organization that really needs it
well for sure just give us quickly Brett
a sense of how your community your
province has been coping with the
pandemic what are some of the stories
you've heard from people well Canadians
in general are very tough here in my
province of Alberta we've definitely
been hit by tough times but I know we're
all trying to look for the silver lining
in this and that's why I wanted to do
this concert to raise spirit for
Albertans as well as do it as we've now
announced that we've got three sold-out
shows in Regina Saskatchewan next
weekend so maybe this thing might
snowball into a few more shows in a few
more places do you think this might be
the way of the future Brett that others
will start copying you you know what I'm
not sure if this is the way of the
future it's kind of the way of the
present right now this is the best that
we can do to bring people together and
bring live music back but as far as I'm
concerned I hope we get back to regular
scheduled programming and we get an
opportunity to play that the real shows
the real way that we want you know
hopefully very soon
[Music]